good evenin to all its us-mexico join
declaration the United States and Mexico
met this week to address the shirt
challenges of irregular irregular
migration to include the entry of
migrants into the United States in
violation of US law even the dramatic
increase in migrants moving from Central
America through Mexico to the United
States both countries recognized the
vital importance of rapidly resolving
the humanitarian emergency and security
situation the governments of the United
States and Mexico will work together to
immediately implement a durable solution
as a result of these discussions the
United States and Mexico committed to a
Mexican enforcement search
Mexico will take unprecedented steps to
increase enforcement to curb irregular
migration to include the deployment of
its National Guard throughout Mexico
giving priority to its southern border
Mexico is also taking decisive action to
dismantle human smuggling and
trafficking organizations as well as
their illicit financial and
transportation networks additionally the
United States and Mexico commit to
strengthen bilateral cooperation
including information sharing and
coordinated actions to better protect
and secure our common border modern
protection protocols
the United States will immediately
expand the implementation of the
existing migrant protection protocols
across its entire southern border this
means that the those crossing the u.s.
southern border to seek asylum will be
rapidly returned to Mexico where they
may await the adjudication of their
asylum claims in response Mexico will
authorize the entrance of all of those
individuals for humanitarian reasons in
compliance with its international
obligations while they await the
adjudication of their asylum claims
Mexico will also offered jobs health
care and education according to its
principles the United States commits to
work to accelerate the adjudication of
asylum claims and to conclude removal
proceedings as a speciously as possible
further actions both parties also agree
that in the event the measures adopted
do not have the expected results they
will take further actions therefore the
United States and Mexico will continue
their discussions from the terms of
additional understandings to address
irregular migrants called flows and
asylum issues to be completed and
announced within 90 days if necessary
ongoing regional strategy the United
States and Mexico reiterate their
previous statement of December 18 2018
that both countries recognized strong
links between
development and economic growth in
southern Mexico and the success of
promoting prosperity governance and
security in Central America
the United States
in constantly the government
wata mala non-buddhist to promote these
goals the United States and Mexico will
lead in working with regional and
international partners to build a more
prosperous and secure Central America to
address the underlying causes of
migration so that citizens of the region
can build better lives for themselves
and their families at the country and
home of origin thank